-Trevor, I thought it
would be fun to play
a brand-new game together.
It is time for "First Try."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ "First Try" ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We will both have to
complete the same challenge,
but we have to do it
on the first try.
Okay, there are no redos
and no second chances.
Whoever completes
the most challenges
on the first try wins.
You ready for this?
-Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I need to understand the rules.
-Yeah. There's no real --
-We're doing something
for the first time?
-Yeah.
-And we have to do it
on the first try?
-That's correct.
It's something
we've probably done before,
but now the pressure is on.
You have do it just -- You have
one chance to do it right.
-I mean, I'll try,
but, I mean --
-That's the whole point of --
-Let's see.
-That's the whole point
of the game.
-Alright, let's see.
Let's see. Let's do it.
-The first challenge is --
I'm doing it since I'm the host.
It's plugging in a USB cord
the correct way without looking.
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
Wait, wait. Without looking?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
So don't look, don't look.
Wait, wait wait, wait.
Let me...
-Oh, look,
you're flipping it around?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Alright, here we go.
-Okay, go. Don't look.
Don't look. Don't look.
♪♪
Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That's good.
That's a point for me.
That's how fun
and random the game is.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you very much.
I feel great.
You have your
USB thing there.
-Yeah, but I don't have a USB --
like, I don't have a hard drive.
I've never done this before.
Someone was like, "Aww."
[ Laughter ]
I'm lying.
I've got a USB drive somewhere.
-Here we go.
-Alright.
-Can he do it first try?
Oh, he can!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes! Yes!
-Alright, alright, alright.
-Yes!
-That is good right there.
Alright, fantastic.
For this next one, okay,
we have to open this book.
You have an advantage here.
-Okay.
-This is your book.
-Alright.
-Paperback. "Born a Crime."
So this is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, thank you. Okay.
-Alright, now,
you have to open the book
to exactly somewhere between
pages 200 and 250
without looking.
-Yeah, you ready?
-Mm-hmm.
♪♪
-Oh.
149?!
[ Tuba plays ]
-217! Yeah, baby!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Alright, this one...
This one's hard.
-Can I just say for the record?
The game I'm having
a fun time with.
I'm enjoying this with you.
That sound effect
is unnecessary.
[ Tuba plays ]
-Yeah, no, that really -- Yeah.
-That is just like --
-That's like taking
a bicycle home, isn't it?
-I mean, that is,
like, a terrible sound.
It doesn't match
what you're trying in life.
[ Tuba plays ]
-Okay.
-Okay, let's do it.
What are we doing here?
-This next round, we're going to
have to flip the water bottle
and have it
land straight up on the desk.
Since you're my guest,
you go first.
-Oh, man, this is -- No!
Okay, wait.
I used to remember
how to do this.
Wait. Alright, hold on, hold on.
♪♪
The keyboard --
-Yeah, I know.
The keyboard was there.
We'll move the keyboard.
I think what
you're trying to do is this.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's no way.
No.
[ Tuba plays ]
-Alright, wait, wait.
This one, let's try to --
-[ Laughs ]
-Let's just try to do it again.
Whoever can do it
the first time.
-Okay.
-We're changing the rules
a little bit here.
-Alright. I'll try again.
I'll try again.
So, when you were standing up,
was that easier?
-That was easier.
I liked standing up.
[ Groans ]
[ Tuba plays ]
-We're going to fight.
♪♪
No. No.
[ Tuba plays ]
-Okay, I'm just gonna keep
flipping this thing.
I'm just going to
keep flipping this bottle.
I'm not going to fail.
-There's a slide there.
-Almost, almost.
-Oh, God. Way off. Let me get...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's what I'm talking
about right there.
Oh, that's how you
do it right there.
Come on, now!
-I'm going to have nightmares
about that sound.
-I know.
-Oh, man.
-He's exhausted. Alright.
Do we have time for one more
first try, first time?
-Alright.
-That was amazing right there.
We could have
ended it right there,
and that would have
been perfect.
But, instead, this one is ---
-Eat the popcorn without
it getting stuck in your teeth.
-No.
-Oh.
-Toss it up in the air
and then catch it in your mouth.
-Oh, yeah, no.
I think I can do that first try.
-I think I can do
that first try. Ready?
-Okay.
-Alright.
♪♪
Yeah, that wasn't good bite.
Ready?
-Wait, wait, wait.
-Yeah, a little breeze.
-A little breeze.
-Yeah.
Here we go. 1, 2, 3...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-He's the winner.
That's the champ right there!
-The wind.
-Trevor Noah!
-The wind is blowing.
-"The Daily Show
with Trevor Noah"
returns with
new episodes on Monday.
Tickets to the
"Back to Abnormal" tour
are available at trevornoah.com.